on vous remercie d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors une attaque
intervient alors que l'équipe de
négociateurs afghan et les talibans en
bois bientôt démarrer des pourparlers de
paix on rappelle inédit le dialogue
paraît pour l'instant très compliqué
alors cet attentat advient dans un
contexte aussi très symbolique puisque
il ya 19 ans un des chefs compagnon
compagnons d'armes frères d'armes de
amrullah saleh ahmed shah massoud était
assassiné en 2001 lançant évidemment une
initiative qui a vu la communauté
internationale est représente déjà
depuis une plus d'une vingtaine d'années
en afghanistan reste cet attentat n'est
pas le premier qui vise une personnalité
très déterminée a dénoncé les
compromissions vis-à-vis d'un certain
nombre d'acteurs qui sont régulièrement
accusés comme étant responsable de
l'instabilité en afghanistan nommément
le pakistan amrullah saleh est un ancien
chef des services de renseignements
c'est comme je le disais un tadjik un
compagnon d'armes de l'alliance du nord
qui avait combattu armes à la main en
2001 les talibans et à bruz la salle et
avait été victime l'été dernier en 2019
à redon d'un précédent attentat qui
avait coûté la mort d'une vingtaine de
personnes amrullah saleh dénoncent
régulièrement cet accord que vous
mentionnez l'accord de paix qui a été
signé à doha le 29 février dernier les
talibans ont été très prompt à dire
qu'ils n'étaient pas responsables de
cette attaque mais il faut avoir à
l'esprit qu'il ya quelques jours à me
laisse aller dans un tweet avait pointé
la responsabilité du voisin du pakistan
en mettant en avant que peshawar était
je cite la capitale d'hiver de l'état
islamique et en remettant en cause le
tracé de la ligne durand qui depuis 1949
n'est pas reconnu par l'état afghan
alors qu'il matérialise la frontière
entre les deux pays
alors justement l'explosion
d'aujourd'hui n'a rien à voir avec nous
ce sont les termes du porte-parole des
talibans est ce que c'est possible parce
que
on sait qu'il a une crédibilité derrière
ces propos déjà il faut avoir à l'esprit
que les talibans le soap en un accord
qui est très matérialiser dans le sens
où il a de nombreux leaders
il y à de nombreuses oppositions et
parfois même des personnalités qui ne se
sont pas associés à l'accord de paix que
nous avons mentionné précédemment
on pense d'ailleurs à quelqu'un dont la
responsabilité de plus en plus pointés
dans le cadre de cet attentat c'est le
chef du réseau des haqqani
sirajuddin haqqani sirajuddin haqqani
dont les responsabilités sont très
régulièrement rapprocher des services de
renseignement pakistanais c'est une des
raisons pour laquelle amrullah saleh l'a
régulièrement ne cesse de fustiger je
cite l'inacceptable ingérence et la
soumission du peuple afghan à son voisin
pakistanais
tout ça pour dire que hamr la salle et
est depuis longtemps la cible de ceux
qui soutiennent les talibans
en l'occurrence l'état voisin alors je
suis évidemment pas capacité de dire si
oui ou non la responsabilité des
talibans est avéré ce qui est certain
c'est que il y à un contexte dans lequel
l'accord de paix qui est dénoncé par les
afghans eux mêmes
peut-être même d'ailleurs pas les
américains de manière plus modeste
laisse interrogatif cet accord de paix
indiqué la libération de cinq mille
prisonniers afghans dont certains
d'ailleurs pose problème les six
derniers prisonniers qui ne sont pas
libérés le sont parce qu'il ya un
blocage de la part de l'australie de la
france puisque nous avons fait valoir
que ces six talibans étaient directement
responsables de la mort de soldats
français durant notre présence entre
2001 et 2014 et donc cet accord de paix
et pour l'instant incomplet mais encore
une fois cet accord de paix n'a de nom
que la manière dont les américains et
les talibans le voit en fait il s'agit
moins d'un accord visant à stabiliser
l'afghanistan que de préparer un retrait
américain
votre reportage précise que le président
donald trump dans une de ses promesses
électorales
alice à l'aune du prochain scrutin du 3
novembre avait annoncé le départ des
soldats américains il ya quelques heures
le président donald trump a dit qu il
et accélérer ce retrait il y a pour
l'instant encore 8600 soldats américains
sur le territoire afghan et il pourrait
y avoir d'ici les prochaines semaines
près de 4000 ou 5000 soldats américains
qui partirait en tout cas un des
éléments qui posent problème dans
l'accord de paix c'est que bien
évidemment les américains légitime le
fait que cet accord de paix a d'une
certaine façon permis de stabiliser
l'afghanistan ce n'est pas tout à fait
la manière dont d'autres acteurs le voit
notamment le nu qui précise que depuis
que l'accord a été signé le 29 février
dernier 1500 personnes sont mortes
malgré la promesse des talibans de ne
pas s'en prendre à la population civile
emmanuel dupuis merci je rappelle que
vous êtes président de l'institut
prospective et sécurité en europe merci